yo this new record scared money
incredible record um
i loved i mean
i think that you know you played a lot
of the album for me a little while ago
and it sounded incredible but um
the video was crazy i just saw the video
looks like you guys i mean that [ __ ]
what was that like a four or five day
shoot so many different scenes so many
different the giant crate challenge like
you know that [ __ ] was like a [ __ ]
it was a three-day shoot but then
uh we were shooting it the song was
supposed to been come out uh during the
video shoot
a lot of the staff and people call code
that i had called kobe
so we had to push the
song back the video shoot
all that type of [ __ ] had to spend all
this extra money to get the [ __ ] cause
of kobe but um we finally
uh got it done and um should be the
record is out now
yeah i feel like it's like one of them
ones you know i feel like
it feels like a big bank it feels like
you know it's gonna it's gonna it's
gonna do do that kind of number like
like when you first cut the record did
you feel that way yes i did
uh i cut the record and i told my people
i'm like bro
this is my first single and my piece was
like bro it's too early i said no my
[ __ ] i know when i got a record like
you fear me
was j cole eat like an easy call to make
um
like what you mean like like you just
you hit him directly there's a label
like you know is it a label thing or is
it i hate him i hit him
i had his number because i had bumped
into him
um
during covey you said he was doing a
commercial for his shoes
and i was in production for my shoe so
he came and he saw my whole program with
my shoes and [ __ ] then we were just
talking about fatherhood and all this
i connected with him but um you know i
uh knew jacob for a minute and [ __ ] he
brought me on this tour like 2015 so
you think he been supporting you know
what i'm saying my whole [ __ ] so uh you
sent me the call wasn't like
like i don't like reaching out to people
that i don't got no history with it like
nope just like yeah
to try to do some music with bro that
should be weird like
you know what i'm saying um so yeah the
j cole [ __ ] was like more on like
organic side like you know